so you're Jordan gujo a former Special
Forces soldier with a fairly decent
history earning three Bronze Stars in
Iraq and Afghanistan for bravery with
the Green Berets your friends had
nothing but good stuff to say about you
and described you as top of your class
more than what most people can say about
themselves you were a self proclaimed
freedom fighter but like many lifelong
war fighters when your time in the
military was up you're left with the
challenge of finding your place and
boring bland society you know we say
that uh combat is like life but
amplified and intensified one of the
craziest aspects of it is many want to
be back there many experience that life
tuned up to eleven and they they recall
it like it's the best time of their life
there's no doubt about it the best time
of my life that's crazy
and that challenge came with equally
troubling money problems in 2013 you
were being investigated for allegedly
defrauding the army of sixty two
thousand dollars in housing allowances
am i 2018 you were more than a hundred
thousand dollars in debt around the same
time you started your private security
firm called silver corp USA no more
exhilarating combat drowning in debt
something's gotta give
fast-forward to march 2020 and the US
announced that they're in guiding
Venezuela's very sketchy president
Nicolas Maduro along with his cronies on
charges of money laundering drug
trafficking and conspiring sent 250
metric tons of cocaine to the US every
year this is the same Venezuela has been
experiencing massive food shortages
hyperinflation the largest refugee
crisis ever recorded in the Americas
thanks to the Maduro administration in
the previous President Hugo Chavez a
true socialist nightmare that's cool and
all but the thing that really catches
your eye is the whopping 15 million
dollar bounty the US declared first
capture
this is to get rich quick scheme you've
been waiting for by this time you've
already been conveniently rewarded a
very fat contract to take down murderer
from his arch-nemesis one guardo this
contract was for a very respectable 1.5
million dollar retainer and 213 million
dollars in future payoffs but that deal
eventually fell through as you were
preparing for the invasion making the
u.s. is 15 million dollar bounty even
more important you're a badass former
SpecOps soldier that can take on the
world you were already planning on
invading Venezuela in the first place
it's like this was made for you that 15
million dollar bounty and maybe even
bigger payoffs from the people who would
take his throne is practically yours
right what could go wrong
pretty much everything if you're gonna
overthrow a government no matter how
much of a badass you are you're gonna
need some help so now it's time to
recruit your all-star team although
Venezuela has been in turmoil for years
now a lot of this current drama started
in 2019 when Nicolas Maduro won a second
term as president in a very sketchy
election with the u.s. calling it a de
facto dictatorship this caused a LOF up
war in the nation with many soldiers
defecting and fleeing to the neighboring
country of Colombia one of the surgeries
that you teamed up with was a guy named
Calibri Alcala Alcala was a retired
general in the Venezuelan army so he's
got a lot of connections knows the lay
of the land and can give this coup a lot
of power behind it pretty great
not so great was the fact that Alcala
was equally as sketchy as the president
you're trying to take down which is why
when they US eventually announced the 15
million dollar bounty on the president
they also put a bounty on your good
friend Alcala for up to ten million
dollars now you can probably tell how
sketchy Alcala is but you remind
yourself that you're a freedom fighter
at hearts and if you take down president
Maduro not only would you get your money
but you'll also go down in history as
the hero and the single-handedly
liberated in Venezuela starving people
from the wrath of their evil dictator so
the ends justify the means of working
with Alcala with the you and your drug
trafficking general teamed up it's time
to put together the soldiers Alcala
already had around 300 low-ranking
defect the soldier staying in camps
around the very north of Colombia and
Venezuela
it's not off the most sense they're not
trained but you do run a security
company after all you and your other
former spec ops guys can easily train
these guys for the coo coo not so
perfect was the fact that not only
Willie's men untrained but their camps
didn't have running water the soldiers
barely had any food to eat and were
malnourished and they had to use
sawed-off broomsticks as pretend a Soul
rifles for training because they didn't
have enough of the real thing worse yet
you were having a very hard time getting
all the weapons and cash needed for this
attack drug-dealing general hungry
untrained troops lack of equipment not
the SEAL Team six you were hoping for
but for the money status and freedom
we'll make it work
you are a professional after all so now
it's time to put together the operation
code named Operation Gideon after a
biblical story that symbolizes a small
military winning against a bigger one
the plan for invading the country you
knew very little about what's pretty
simple your army of 300 will roll in on
some very sleek Navy SEAL style
inflatable boats are of your mouth
Norrish men would then capture and
maintain control of the biggest airport
in venezuela simone Bulevar
international airport while your other
men would infiltrate the Capitol
building where Maduro is a palace in the
capital of Caracas your men would then
capture Maduro and their how they would
do that I'm not totally sure I guess
we'll find out when we actually get
there while all this is happening
ideally your invasion was sparking a
popular rebellion in the locos to help
you along the way and boom Maduro will
be in Florida to face prosecution
you'll get your money to pay off all
your debts and make you a pretty rich
man in the process and you'll be hailed
as the man who single-handedly
orchestrated the modern day revolution
of Venezuela reality however was much
different
[Music]
leading up to the invasion things were
going okay more the factors were being
recruited into the camps even if the
money and equipment wasn't arriving and
you were training the hell out of them
but then almost in an instant the house
of cards fell down one of your soldiers
was stopped driving to the safe house
when a truck filled to the brim with
$150,000 in assault rifles body armor
and equipment this was also around the
same
your drug-dealing general Alcala was
also indented alongside Maduro with his
very own bounty of ten million dollars
leading him to turn himself in which
understandably didn't inspire a much
faith in your hungry recruits and the
original deal you had for a 1.5 million
dollar retainer and 213 million dollars
in future payoffs fell through but if we
look hard enough there is still a silver
lining in this mess Alcala wasn't alone
the u.s. also put a very juicy fifteen
million dollar bounty on Maduro even
though your generals in custody even
though most of your troops are
discouraged even though your original
deal of over 200 million dollars fell
through you're already far too deep in
the scheme to back out now you can't go
home empty-handed and while 15 million
is only a fraction of the original deal
it's still more than enough and you
determine that's won't worth the risk
so on May 3rd 2022 of your ex Green
Berets and 60 of the original 300
Venezuelan soldiers set sail to put your
glorious plan into action
1700 hours a daring and Phidias raid was
launched from the border of Colombia
deep into the heart of Caracas now of
course you didn't go because well you're
the director of this whole scheme after
all what do but the bounty be to you if
you were dead so you let your brave men
sail in for you except instead of those
sleek and fast inflatable boats they
drifted in on paddle boats and instead
of invading they were surrounded by the
time they landed which resulted in 8
soldiers getting killed and your 2x
Green Berets getting captured it turns
out that your previous partner in the
drug dealing general Alcala couldn't
keep his mouth shut about the plan which
eventually made its way into the
Venezuelan government early on this
allowed them to infiltrate the rebels in
Venezuela's intelligence networks said
quotes we knew everything they were so
infiltrated that minerals administration
even pay for some of their meetings in
the aftermath maderos victory and the
two captured Americans were paraded
around to show the strength of Maduro as
Venezuela murderous 15 million dollar
bounty is still up for grabs and last we
heard US law enforcement is
investigating our would-be bounty hunter
goudreau but nothing else has come up so
if you're looking to collect that 15
million dollar bounty if you're looking
to overthrow a government well at least
you know what not
and that ladies and gentlemen concludes
just another chapter in the very
eventful year of 2020 but let's be real
even with everything going on in the
world right now and there are much
easier ways to make money in this
beautiful world than to abduct a
dictator to collect the bounty one great
way to make money is with a remote job
this is where today's video sponsor
comes in you if you enjoy today's video
and you want to support this channel
financially completely optional by the
way check out the course I made on how
to land a remote job with the link below
this is how I got started in this hole
make money online thing with a $40 per
hour remote well that job and I believe
it's one of the most practical ways for
others like you to get started as well
compared to jumping into trying to make
a business right away you can think of a
remote job as a jumping off points you
learn the skills you need in business
from home while still making consistent
income so you're not starving to death
like those poor Venezuelan soldiers even
though the competition for remote jobs
has skyrocketed thanks to the pandemic
specific remote jobs like digital
marketing have also grown too but no
matter what happens the world is always
open to more ingrate irreplaceable team
members and you can start your remote
journey right now with the link below
for a very reasonable price that Peter
says he would have paid a lot more money
for no webinars no BS just everything I
would have wanted to know when I was
trying to go remote with the link below
welcome to the watch to the end Club a
ton of you guys have been requesting and
requesting me to make a video on private
military contractors I honestly don't
know why you guys are so interested in
that but it is in the pipeline so in
like the meantime that's why I made this
video to like give you guys a temporary
fix before like while I'm preparing to
make my other video but it is in the
pipeline so you know don't worry so if
you don't want to miss that video
consider subscribing to this channel
because it's free and you can dislike
and unsubscribe whenever you want and
you will get free video essays just like
this one every single week on the most
provocative stuff in the world business
I want to give a quick shout out to my
friend Alex over at the business casual
YouTube channel and this guy he is he's
a real entrepreneur he's built and sold
multiple startups and every time I talk
to him I always find myself learning
something like really cool and new they
have a new documentary out called JP
Morgan how one man - America so if you
enjoyed this video you will probably
enjoyed that video - so I will link it
below for you guys to check
and we didn't pay me to say this
although in a lot you can follow me on
instagram at jake trend io for more
behind-the-scenes stuff sometimes I post
teasers on there etc so that's pretty
much gonna wrap it up thank you so much
for watching you've been awesome
I've been Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]